[Music]
we hear about the 24-hour news cycle all
the time the reality is due to our
fast-paced lives and ever splintering
attention span stories really only stay
in the news for about 24 hours and when
stories do stick around for more than
that the cable news shows and online
Outlets feel the need to deliver us the
news in the fastest flashiest and often
sloppiest fashion possible in the
political world this need for excitement
leads us going from Scandal to Scandal
or he said she said instead of focusing
on the real issues that affect our
everyday lives I mention this
never-ending Matrix of information
because I find along the way instead of
talking about the right things our
national conversation almost always
talks about the wrong things we debate
whether Trump's wall is racist rather
than discussing whether a nation should
protect its borders as it sees fit we
talk about a $15 minimum wage without
questioning whether it will lead to
McDonald's replacing all its employe
employees with iPads we argue about
income inequality without really taking
the time to think about what the role of
government should be on top of all this
then we get our news from a pundit class
filled with former politicians and
campaign people who pretend to be
neutral when they usually couldn't be
anything further from it of course in
this election the pundits almost all
predicted everything wrong the whole
time especially on the Republican side
but for some reason we still turn to
them to predict how the future of
America will play out when you add up
the fast news cycle with the networks
who just want views and online creators
who just want clicks you get exactly
what we're left with right now a whole
lot of noise often it's seemingly
impossible to figure out what is true or
even who is trying to tell you the truth
throw in an American education system
which has been co-opted by safe spaces
and Trigger warnings instead of critical
thinking and you have a toxic mess
designed to cater to the simplest
and worst parts of ourselves the more
you scream bloviate and demonize the
more it somehow seems you are right
righteous indignation has become the new
truth but actually it's just a bunch of
which is why on the Rubin
report I try to focus on Big Ideas and
not get bogged down in The Daily Grind
of nonsensical news stories or the
endless horse race of the political
season my guest this week is yuron
Brooke the president and ex executive
director of the Ein Rand Institute just
by saying the name Ein Rand there I know
some people's heads will explode Ein was
an author and philosopher best known for
her books The Fountain Head and Atlas
Shrugged she created the philosophy
known as objectivism which she described
as quote the concept of man as a heroic
being with his own happiness as the
moral purpose for his life with
productive achievement as his noblest
activity and reason as as his only
absolute a and her work are revered by
many people on the right and despised by
many people on the left people on the
right tend to love her emphasis on the
individual while people on the left tend
to revile her dismissal of the
collective so much of what's happening
in the country right now from The Bernie
Revolution to the social justice Warrior
movement to the rise of trump can be
explained or at the very least discussed
within the prism of objectivism I'm
going to dive deep into it with uran and
see if we can come up with some answers
to solve some of the problems of today
what is man's highest Pursuit what is
the role of government can we live for
ourselves and still help others these
are just a couple of the questions that
I want to get into whether you agree or
disagree with all the answers that
you'll hear is largely irrelevant we
need to discuss big issues so that our
conversations aren't dominated by little
Minds joining me this week is yone
Brooke president of the irran Institute
and co-author of the book equal is
unfair yone welcome to the show thanks
for having me on I am very excited to
talk to you because you guys sent me
literature usually usually people send
me a book maybe I got the book too but I
got literature I've done a tremendous
amount of reading over last couple of
days so I'm looking forward to this so
IR Rand I mentioned at the top of the
show if just by saying her name just by
saying IR brand a certain percentage of
people go Bonkers go completely Bonkers
I'm sure I'm sure I'm not Illuminating
you on anything no so so before we get
into the the specifics of objectivism
and her philosophy and all that tell me
a little bit just about her as the
president of the I mean irand was born
to a middle class Jewish Family in uh in
St Petersburg Russia she was Alicia
Rosenblum right that was her name and uh
she witnessed uh communism she she saw
it happen she lived under it in her
teenage years and it was clear given her
personality that she was not going to
survive she was not going to live
through communism she was going to get
in trouble so the family got together
and they and they got her out and
basically there was a window of
opportunity where lenon allowed some
people out to do research or do
something with their studies she got out
in her early 20s came to the United
States with nothing spent some time with
family CH calledo but then showed up in
Hollywood uh her dream was to be a
script writer to be a writer and and she
she loved Hollywood movies she lefted
silent movies and she goes the first day
she goes to the C be de Mill Studios and
you know with a letter of introduction
and they say don't call us we'll call
you she walks out and there's this big
convertible and CA de is sitting right
there and he drives by and she's staring
at she's this little Russian woman she's
staring at him with these big eyes and
he stops the car and he says why are you
staring and she tells him the story I'm
here from Russia I love your movies he
says get in wow and he takes it the back
lot where they're filming the king of
kings story of Jesus Christ and he says
here's a week-long pass so that you can
see how movies are made you want to be
in the movie business this is how movies
are made so she does that she lands up
being an extra in the movie she lands up
meeting a future husband on the set and
this is a entry point into Hollywood and
and she gets many many little jobs in
Hollywood as at night she is writing and
practicing her English and um she works
in the wardrobe Department she works as
extras she works in all but in the end
she becomes a script writer and she
writes some scripts some of the some of
the movies are made uh and in addition
she writes a couple of plays they are
put on in both LA and uh and on Broadway
she writes a book called We The Living
which is uh the most autobiographical
thing she ever wrote which is about a
young woman growing up under communism
in the Soviet Union and the choices she
has to make and so what what were some
of those what were some of those things
before we what were some of the failures
that she had to deal with or what were
some of the things that she had to live
under with commun in communist well you
know you couldn't express your own
opinion uh you had a uh play out the
party line her father who owned a
pharmacy a private Pharmacy it was
nationalized it was taken away from him
they went from living a middle class
life in a nice kind of apartment to
sharing an apartment with other families
um they during the Civil War in Russia
they they escaped to the to the to the
Black Sea and then had to go back to St
Petersburg and just the graininess
the Conformity the everybody being the
same the the the lack of any
opportunities the lack of any future
what what what are you going to do
you're always going to be the same yeah
there's no progress there's no there's
no success there no advancement you are
expected to conform to standard and this
is what we the living is about it's a
brilliant book it's a it's a short book
and it was made into movie by uh in
Italy in 1942 I think and later we
discovered in the 1960s um the book
failed and the book failed because New
York intelligencia in the 1930s were
kind of enamored with Communism right
communism was kind of cool right and
here was a book saying no communism was
evil and it was really one of the first
books to paint that picture of Communism
this is what's actually going on in
Russia not what you're reading in the
New York Times which is propaganda but
this is what's actually going on she
then wrote A L book called um Anthem
which she couldn't find a publisher for
in the United States and landed up being
published in the
UK a year or two before 1984 so it's
kind of a dystopian novel and there's
there's evidence that all well probably
read it um and then she wrote a book
called The Fountain Head and and the
Fountain Head was rejected by 12
Publishers ultimately published became a
word of mouth bestseller to this day
sells over 100,000 copies a year is is a
bestseller has shaped and influenced the
lives of many many people it's about an
architect yeah and I don't know any
architect out there yeah I don't know
any architect out there hasn't read The
Fountain Head hasn't been impacted by
The Fountain Head uh it took a 12 years
to write an X book Atlas Shrugged uh and
that book became an instant bestseller
you know Publishers competed for it and
then she spent the rest of her life that
was published in
1957 she spent the rest of her life she
died in ' 82 writing non-fiction
developing the philosophy that she had
uh discovered for Atlas Shrug that she
really developed in Atlas Shrug but
really articulating its applications and
all kinds of VAR so she wrote
newsletters and articles and books of
essays from 19 all through the 60s and
into the 70s and and again she died in
1982 uh working you know while she was
still still writing and and very active
yeah so I wanted to get a little bit of
her history out because I feel like
people don't know some of the history
that this is someone who came from
communism who came to love America and
capitalism and sort of living for
yourself which is a lot of what
objectivism is so now let's unpack
objectivism a little bit there are sort
of there are five pillars and give me
the
the broadest objectivism bre so so
objectivism in one foot kind of is in
metaphysics which is which is the the
Aran philosophy that that studies what
is out there what is reality about you
know it's reality is what it is a is a
kind of law of identity the law of
causality Aristotle's view of of the
metaphysical nature of reality reality
is not created by another being it's not
what we want it to be it's not what we
wish it to be it's not what some
external Consciousness created it just
is it's here and now it's here and now
okay it's and we and we have and this is
kind of the epistemology we have the
tool to know it we have senses to
observe it and we have reason to be able
to integrate it understand it and and
actually ultimately shape it it's not a
creation of our
Consciousness uh it's not a creation of
our emotions the way the way you learn
about reality is not through emotions
it's through reason it's through science
it's through using you know what's
uniquely human which is our our
reasoning capacity our rational thinking
our senses and our senses are valid now
thinking being re having reason being
rational is a characteristic of the
individual we don't have a collective
stomach to eat we don't have a
collective mind to think only
individuals can think so the
unit uh in ethics is the individual the
the purpose of ethics
is to provide guidance for the
individual on how to live the best life
that he can live what values and virtues
to pursue to live a great life and to
live a life consistent with our nature
as human beings as rational reasoning
beings so ethics is not about teaching
us how to sacrifice for other people how
to die for them but it's also not about
getting other people to sacrifice for us
and and and exploiting other people it's
about living a full rational life right
so okay so let's let's three that's
three right so let's pause there for a
second so a lot of what I've talked
about here is that one of my problems
with what has become the modern left is
that they seem to now care more about
the collective than the individual and
aan hery Ali who I've had on you know
she always talks about if you care about
minorities you have to care about
minorities within minorities that's very
much an objectivist way of looking at
things well man said the smallest
minority in the world is the individual
that's what it's all about so the
framework for everything in politics in
Morality is the individual not the group
but you see the all left has bigger
problems in my view yeah that is the the
the the modern left has rejected the
idea of reason the idea of reason is
actually being efficacious in the world
uh it's rejected reason as the standard
you know beyond science and even in
science there some questions but beyond
science they rejected reason as the
standard by which we should evaluate
reality and this comes from philosophers
like Kant and Hegel and schopenhauer and
so on the German Continental tradition
which basically said reason is a mind
game it's in here we don't know what
reality is you know we can speculate
about what real reality is but what we
see is ultimately shaped by
Consciousness not by reality our senses
actually distort reality they don't
identify reality that has created a real
epistemological ultimately moral and
political problem throughout the last
150 years so this is where you would say
that we care sort of more about feelings
over fact sometimes things will feel
right to us it seems right to say well
the minimum wage should be $15 because
you want people that are lwi income to
make more money that feels right but it
may not actually be the what the system
itself can uh negotiate it's not what
happens in reality that is and this is
what people call unintended consequences
I'm not sure they're always unintended
but they unintended and consequences is
if you think a little bit more about the
problem and and let's take the minimum
wage yeah if you raise a price
artificially we all studied in econ 101
when a price is raised demand goes down
so if you raise the price of Labor then
demand for that labor goes down and this
happens over and over again and and and
but people don't want believe that but
they also don't want to take the
inductive evidence that is the fact that
it's happened a 100 times oh but this
time it's going to be different and I
see that in economics all the time the
the krugans of the world stimulus never
works it's never worked that's cuz it
hasn't been big enough we need to do
bigger and and it's never going to work
because they they keep loading it up
like that and the same with the minimum
wage they keep thinking this time will
be different but that's anti-reason it's
anti-science and what they're placing is
wishes before facts wishes before solid
theoretical Theory theory that was
derived from evidence from reality I
mean that's the real scientific method
right so when I've watched these debates
let's just stick on the minimum wage
thing for a moment and you know Bernie
says the $15 minimum wage and I said
it's it feels good and I've worked
minimum wage jobs too when I was in high
school I think I was making $6 maybe an
hour or it might have even been less I'm
not even sure but it sounds good but
what they also because they don't think
through well McDonald's if they're
forced to go from 750 and employee or
whatever it is $9 an employee to 15
they're just going to replace them all
with iPads right I mean that's what I
mentioned at the top of the show so
absolutely so uh first of all you're
going to get iPads to take orders iPads
are much more efficient in taking orders
the people are yeah and but but they're
actually machines now that will flip the
burgers that will do the whole process
and bring you out wrap nicely a burger
whatever you ordered on the iPad we'll
get so automation automation is going to
happen anyway right but this speeds it
up and people are less prepared for it
but more than that it's going to mean
the teenagers if you're a teenager
growing up in the inner cities and
you're not trained because public
education is a a disaster so you have no
skills right so now you're expected to
be able to perform at 15 bucks an hour
you can't the fact is nobody will pay
somebody to produce
$10 it won't pay them 15 to produce 10
right I'm not going to lose when I I
tell this to to kids right when somebody
hires you they're going to make money
off of you that's the nature of the
transaction you're G to make money off
of them because your time is actually
worth less than what you're willing to
take at the salary but they're going to
make money off of you nobody's going to
hire a kid who who can't produce more
than seven bucks an hour at 15 bucks an
hour so those kids are just going to be
priced out so whether it means the
McDonald shuts down whether it means
they automate whether it means they
raise they jack up prices significantly
so that people now can't afford to buy
the food that they're producing so that
nothing's changed in that sense it's not
good policy we can talk about how to
help poor people particularly inoc City
kids yeah but minimum wage is the
dumbest stupidest most economic ignorant
idea ever and even Jerry Brown gets it
right because why was this negotiated
here in California they negotiated like
a six-year term to phase it in right
it's because there was a ballot
initiative that was going to go into
effect that would have had minimum wage
go up in the next three years and Jerry
Brown looked at that and said oh my God
this is going to be disastrous for the
California economy so I'll I'll
compromise with these guys by spreading
it out which is the least damaging thing
he could have done but even Jerry Brown
said they're trade-offs and what are the
trade-offs unemployment among young
people uh take some entrepreneurs going
out of business and yes some people will
make a little bit more money those are
the kind of trade-offs that I find ugly
right and this is where critical
thinking is so important because when
I've watched the debates Bernie says the
15 and gets Applause for it because it
sounds good it feels good Hillary said
something like well we're going to get
it to 12 and then figure it out now I'm
not even defending her other than to say
that at least she's trying to play the
game at least of reality right so in a
weird way you you have to credit her
she's doing the Jerry Brown thing right
yes but this is this is a sad thing
about American America right now and
this this is on the right and on the
left because we're seeing the same thing
with Donald Trump is that after what I
believe is about a century of
progressive education where we've taught
kids not to think but to feel not to be
reasoning rational agents but to be
feeling agents we are suffering the
consequence now so we've got politicians
who appeal purely to emotion that don't
discuss facts that don't discuss
evidence don't discuss Trump and Bernie
Trump and Bernie right and don't discuss
how they're going to get there they
don't discuss the details they don't
discuss how they pay for it we're going
to give you free stuff we're going to
we're gonna uh you know we're going to
get back at the chineses if the Chinese
are the problem and so on and so forth
right but it's all emotion it's all
about emotion and if people are
responding and of course you know you've
talked about Free Speech but this is the
same kind of thing we're seeing on on on
American campuses today you can't say
something that might offend somebody or
and what does it mean to offend it means
that it's a little bit out of the
mainstream because their emotions are
hood and we're saying emotions are what
matter we'll give you a safe space we'll
we'll give you we'll give you triggers
we'll protect your emotions no we should
be protecting the mind and the way to
protect the mind is to expand it is to
expose them to lots of different ideas
and teach them the critical thinking
skills that are necessary to figure out
what's right what's wrong what makes
sense what doesn't make sense but that's
out and and I'm this is what scares me
the most about America today it's this
emotionalism so in that sense it's an
epistemological point it's not even
ethics it's not politics this is about
what is the tool for knowing reality is
it emotion or is it the mind yeah well
you're you're throwing me all of my
favorite stuff right there between the
Free Speech stuff and completely in free
spee yeah um so wait so circling back to
objectivism did we did we miss any piece
of it sure we
politics if individuals are the moral
unit if the purpose of morality is to
guide us towards our own individual
happiness if the purpose of morality is
to give us the values and virtues and if
it turns out as objectivism holds that
the most important of those is reason so
our Cardinal value if you will is is to
cultivate your reason your ver the most
important virtue The Virtue that
integrates all other virtues is
rationality then the question is okay
what kind of a world does a reasoning
rational individual list demand in order
to be able to exercise his reason and
rational and and the answer is freedom
all he wants is to be free to be left
alone so he can exercise his mind and
pursue the values that he believes are
good for him now it might turn out that
he's wrong but then he needs to learn
and and adjust and he needs to make
those decisions and he should be allowed
to make mistakes and the enemy of reason
is force the enemy of reason is coion so
what we want is a political system that
protects us from coion and and the
concept of individual rights which the
enlightenment came up with Lo and then
the founding fathers um is the concept
that recognizes that fact it recognizes
the idea that in order for people to
exercise their reason they have to be
free an individual rights mean this is
the right to life means the pursue the
values necess serve for your life the
right to Liberty means think what you
want to think say what you want to say
write what you want to write you have a
right to use your mind in any way that
you can in Pursuit of Happiness right
that's the ultimate goal so they
recognize this individualism so the core
there
is freedom and the and and and the way I
see Freedom the only free political
system is a capitalist political system
a system in which the government's only
job is to protect us from corrosion its
only job is to protect us from the use
of force so that's for the fifth pillar
which is an whole other area in
philosophy which I don't know if we talk
about is Aesthetics that is given the
type of Consciousness that we have we
need a particular kind of art to reflect
back to us the values that we have so
that it can Inspire us so that it can it
can keep us going it provides us with
important cognitive and emotional fuel
so einan believed in Romanticism as as
that that form of art a representational
it has to represent something but then
it has to inspire and and she defined
Romanticism as art that recognizes the
fact that individuals have free will
right and and all art that recognize
that she would consider a superior art
form to to to other art forms that's
that's the kind but she didn't have to
she didn't have to like the art
specifically right if the if the artists
themselves was expressing all of their
Humanity right uh well the ex the best
example of that is that she loved she
she recognized the genius and the
greatness of Dusty and he she considered
him a romantic artist because you
recognize free will if you read Dusty
you know I mean his characters a torn
between choices right and she loved that
kind of H that was the essence of H but
philosophically she was opposed to
everything dust yvi wrote right she she
she she viewed his view of life as Bleak
as as as as awful um Hugo is another one
Hugo who was a socialist and l z robers
ultimately has kind of a socialist a
plight of the poor type of theme she
considered Hugo the greatest uh literary
figure in human history uh the greatest
writer in human history and and and a
great romantic writer because he had all
these conflicts and this drama which he
loved right so that's really fascinating
so she didn't like the ideas that these
people were putting forth but she loved
them as individuals right she loved the
idea she loved the idea that they were
expressing she loved their aesthetic she
loved the way they communicated the idea
and the recognition so what she
separated is so there's certain
political ideas up here but she believed
that much more important than the
political ideas are the fundamental
philosophical ideas so she looks at Hugo
and he says here's a here's a a great
author who recognizes something very
very important maybe the most important
thing about human beings we have free
will versus many modern artists many
modern authors where the story just
Rambles along nobody makes any choices
everything's by accident she would say
then denying Free Will so even if they
use beautiful Pros Shakespeare is a good
example of this right even if they use
beautiful pros and they write beautiful
stuff because they're denying free will
you know I really really hate that now I
I admire the pros I admire the story I
admire but I but I resent them
philosophically who go because he
recognizes something more fundamental
than politics in a sense I'm willing to
forgive the bad politics because we're
allies on on the more fundamental
philosophy I can get a lot of fuel
spiritual fuel from the recognition of
Heroes even if they're fighting for
something I don't believe in right so
really more than anything else it sounds
to me like she wanted to have the Battle
of ideas and that's very much what I do
here and what I try to get people to
think about and to talk about but
unfortunately we don't seem to live in a
time when this is working right as you
just said between the the the Trump
stuff giving you easy answers and the
Bernie stuff giving you easy answers we
don't live in a time when the underlying
bedrock is cared about but this is the
danger of living in a time where we've
elevated emotions among all else because
once you accept emotions as your
standard there's nothing to talk about
right right because because it it's a
question of well what what you're saying
makes me feel X or what you're saying
makes me feel why but that's not a
conversation a conversation is about
reason it's about ideas it's about proof
it's about evidence and that is that
requires critical thinking skills and we
we have trained maybe several
Generations but certainly the latest
generation not to think to when we when
we have 5-year-olds or seven-year-olds
or 9-year-olds sitting around a
classroom and we ask them what do you
think about something political well
that's ridiculous a 5-year-old doesn't
think about politics he can't think and
even a nine-year-old can't think what
what nine-year-olds need is is a lot of
knowledge a lot of information and the
skills the math and science skills that
train you in how to think and our public
education system has destroyed that so
what she was interested in is reason
Above All She said I'm a champion of
capitalism because I'm a champion of
rational self-interest as my Maro but
I'm a champion of rational self-interest
is my MoGo because I'm a champion of
reason as man's basic means of survival
is his tool of knowledge so the
fundamentaly Ran's philosophy and this
is what I think so many people don't get
and and and they they respond
emotionally to it is reason you know and
a lot of your audience says we're for
science we're for reason we're for facts
we're for science well this is IR
now now we can debate the politics but
let's at least agree that the standard
by which we have this debate is a
standard of rationality it's a standard
of facts and evidence it's so funny
because I tweeted yesterday that I was
having you on and I happen to be
watching Bernie speak and I took a
picture of Bernie speaking in the
background about income inequality then
I had your book in the foreground and
then I tweeted that you were on and then
people immediately and I'm very proud
that we've created something good here
because I have a lot of people on the
left and I have a lot of people on the
right right and I'm trying to get these
people together right um let them have
the conversation and let them have the
conversation and then and then we'll see
and look people will respond in the
comment section to this and they'll say
either well I agreed with X and Y and I
disagree with this or whatever um but
immediately a bunch of people jumped on
you yes and it was and I was watching
the the back and forth and you were
doing it I try not to do the back and
forth on Twitter that much anymore but
you were doing it and you were trying to
cly well read this you know I mean they
were jumping on you but you going well
try this read this or maybe a Mis
understand that and that's where we all
have to get if we're going to move
forward yes and of course it's very hard
to do on Twitter and it's unbelievably
frustrating because Twitter you know you
got this character limit and you have to
make it snappy and catchy and you can't
have a rational conversation on Twitter
this is why I try to say please read the
book or read this article or here's a
link to a video you know because you
can't articulate any kind of case on on
this but I mean what what we are trying
to do is make this a philosophical
debate and and the problem is this today
and this one of my exchanges with one of
your um I think audience followers was
was about this his viewers philosophy is
useless philosophy is a waste of time
it's just it's completely arbitrary it
it's just people rambling right and
that's to some extent true modern
philosophy is completely useless
completely rambling it's detached from
reality what I'm trying to suggest is
there's an alternative view first of all
we all have a philosophy whether we like
it or not whether we know it or not
whether we articulate we're all Guided
by a philosophy but secondly there is
there are alternative philosophies that
are pro-science they're Pro reason
they're pro-act they're so used to this
floating abstractions detached from
reality philosophy that so many people
have abandoned it and that's sad to me
it's very sad because I want them
engaged in that debate particularly
those who are pro science yeah I don't
want science versus philosophy I want
them to try to think what kind of
philosophy is there that is supportive
and enhancing of sence it's no accident
that science a scientific revolution
happens when it does it happens when the
West rediscovers Greek philosophy and
it's no accident that Greece is the is
the start of science because they
philosophically they viewed philosophy
as a tool to understand reality and they
you know arist created the scientific
method he made a lot of mistakes in
science huge mistakes in science sure
but the method method he got it was an
empirical method of testing and
observation and it was because he was
Guided by particular philosophy that
allowed him to do that it was because in
the Renaissance and the and and later in
the enlightenment we had a respect for
for reason and for our senses that
science could develop so the two if you
abandon philosophy you will ultimately
abandon science right so using the
example of Greece you must find
modern-day Greece to be a very
depressing example of of using
philosophy properly because I guess you
would argue they abandoned it because
they have all kinds of problems uh
economically but it's you it's mostly
because they went with more left-wing
policies well so again yes it's leftwing
policies but leftwing policies are
driven by philosophical approach so I
view this is Ein Rand and and and other
thinkers within objectivism you know
view all of history as in a sense a
battle between Aristotle and
Plato and you can find
all the bad policies that Greece that we
that that you know even even the
emotionalism all of those link back to
Plato and all the good stuff links to
Aristotle Scientific Revolution the
enlightenment the the the the America as
a as a free country all in the Arista
tilian tradition and there's a constant
philosophical fight going on Plato
believed that we all live in a cave that
we don't know real reality and we need
philosophic Kings who somehow commune
with the will to form Ms to know what
the truth is so you need a pope to talk
to God to tell us the truth or you need
leaders right whether they're tribal
leaders whether they're political
leaders who know what's good for all of
us because we are still in a cave and we
don't know what's good for that's where
authoritarianism and modern kind of
democracy comes from Aristotle believed
that each one of us has the capacity to
reason for himself and that the purpose
of morality Aristotle's very similar to
IR Rand here the purpose of morality for
Aristotle is to guide us towards UDA
which is flourishing so individual
flourishing and then you know while I
might disagree with the particular
things that he advised people to do in
order to achieve happiness the goal is
the same now it's just a scientific
question what actually leads to human
flu right so okay so for the Plato
version of this of you're in a cave
basically it's saying that we need we
need somebody upstairs whether either a
religious figure as you said or the pope
or just people that we elect or some
leader in those terminology some leader
to because we can't do it ourselves now
obviously I buy into the Aristotle
version of this but I think what a lot
of people would say is well if everyone
is doing what they think is best for
themselves this is this is the main
critique I've heard I was watching you
once on John stasel on Fox Business I
think and somebody was was asking you
about this that if everyone is doing
what they think is best for themselves
that that really is
anarchy well but it's not because the
caveat in that is what's good for you is
not to exploit other people exploiting
other people is bad for you right and
and I have whole seminars on why lying
stealing cheating uh is just bad for you
it's destructive to your own soul your
own ability to communicate with other
people and also we have to realize
what's doing good for you means being
rational about it right reason is the
fundamental so you really have to think
I tell people if you want to be selfish
in the way howan talks about selfishness
right if you really want to do what's
good for you it's hard hard work you
have to really think about it right most
people think oh being selfish is like
what a 2-year-old does and I'm saying no
a 2-year-old doesn't know what he's
doing right is just Guided by emotion
they don't have the frontal cortex is
not developed enough for them to reason
themselves into self-interest right
self-interest requires thought it
requires figuring out okay I've got 50
years to live if you're young right um
what is the best path for me to take
what are the choices I should make is
honesty does honesty make sense not as a
commandment from above not as as
something that Society tells tells me
but does honesty make sense for me and I
would argue absolutely you know being
dishonest is just stupid policy it's
really really bad for you if you think
about it as rational long-term
self-interest and if we're all
rationally long-term self-interested
there's no Clash there's no I mean we
we're not trying to exploit what is the
relationship people have with one
another if they're pursuing their own
self-interest it's trade I want you to
be successful because when you're
successful you're producing and creating
values that make me more successful I
love Apple because I get to buy an
iPhone for 300 bucks and it's made my
life significantly better and it much
worth much more to me than 300 bucks
Apple won I won I love my wife because
you know my life is better because of
having a relationship with her her life
is better I hope for having a
relationship with me right right I'll
have her on next week we'll that so all
of life for rationally self-interested
human being is about win-win
relationship this is another thing I
hate about Trump Trump views life in
terms of winners and losers I view life
in terms of winners and winners right
and and yeah we I'm going to win at the
same rate right some of us will be
incredibly successful but then also what
does success mean I mean I find it
interesting that the left always
measures success in terms of dollars and
I don't measure success in terms of
dollars I I chose to be a teacher I
could have gone to Wall Street because I
love what I do and this is this is much
more fun than having millions of dollars
in the bank account yeah right so it's
about having a great life it's not about
how many dollars you accumulate and
we're all going to we all have the
opportunity to win and it's not when you
win it's not at somebody's expense it's
the opposite the only way to make money
the only way to be successful is to
provide a value to somebody else right
so that's really interesting so that
you'd say that the left would look at
this and say well this just get this is
just unleashing the the chains
unshackling people to be purely selfish
but really what you're saying is if you
were left to your own device well you're
giving me your own personal example but
that the average person left to their
own devices it's not that you just want
to be selfish just to make money because
you also want the people around you to
be happy and you want your family to be
happy and you want your community to be
better and people are operating under
this idea without even realizing it
right absolutely but but I mean let's be
clear I'm not saying that if you just
Unleashed everybody tomorrow everybody
would be rationally self-interested
right there are genuinely Bad Peter
genuinely bad people and then there's
some people who just don't think and
therefore will do stupid things yeah
they do it today they they'll continue
to do them but what you're giving is the
opportunity for people who want to be
rational who want to pursue a good life
the opportunity to do it now one of the
things you have to teach people is how
to be mul I I I'm I'm all for moral
education but what morality boils down
for me is teach them how to think how to
think not just about science not just
about the world out there but think
about what about themselves what's good
for me what's what's not good for me
what will lead to a flourishing life
what won't lead to flourishing life so
rather than today self-interest is
associated with doing whatever you feel
like doing it so there's a line of
cocaine there I'm going to get a high
that's in my self-interest right and I'm
going no it's not if if you know
anything about cocaine and people who
take it regularly it's destructive to
your life don't do it so you have a
right to do it right a political right
because you're not csing anybody by
taking the cocaine but do you have our
but should you do it from a m
perspective and I'm saying no not
because you're going to hurt somebody
else but but you're hurting yourself the
most valuable thing you have is you yeah
so don't hurt yourself that's why
so so yes pursue your self-interest but
do it rationally with your long-term
interests in mind okay so everything
that you've said so far about 40 minutes
in I'm I'm pretty much with you this is
where my Evolution has been going so why
have these
ideas haven't why haven't these ideas
had better sellers where are the where
are the where where's the IR Rand of
today I mean obviously this this is what
you are doing and there's plenty of
people that I think are more libertarian
like uh pen Gillette and Michael Shermer
and some other people I know that are
selling these ideas but why where are
the people going man take your life back
and live for yourself and through that
you will you will make the world a
better place they don't exist and or or
there are very few of us and and the
reason is I think is is what we talked
about education I think educational
system has destroyed that where is where
the where the great economists I mean
where's the Milton fredman I mean we
were talking about the minimum wage mil
freed were alive today he would be on
every TV show would be every way
explaining this and it Nobody Does it or
or take Donald Trump's claims about
trade which are ludicrous and bod
Sanders of course agrees with him
they're ludicrous there any Economist
would say and there's nobody nobody
defending them except I I saw really
good editorial from a guy who I hate to
say wrote a really good editorial but he
did alen Blinder who I disagree with on
almost everything in economics and he
wrote this really good opad about free
trade Now where's the Milton Freedman
doing that
you know we just we lack and and I I
don't know as much about science but I I
fear that we we just don't have the the
Einstein and the Newton and the and the
uh uh darwins I I just think that we are
much more mediocre today than we will in
terms of our our Geniuses and maybe our
genius is going to business and the
Steve Jobs is of the world but we don't
seem to have those bigger than life you
know same with novelists where the
victoro go of today I just don't see
those kind of people and I think we've
averaged down in the name by the way
it's related to the book right I think
in the name of equality I think that's
one of the evils of equality is it aages
us down not only on economic terms but
it tries to average us down on on
everything else right so it fully
explains the Trump thing I mean
everything you're saying explains the
Trump thing because we've we've dumbed
ourselves down we we want easy answers
and then he gets up there and he
explains some of this trade stuff so
okay so just for the trade stuff real
quick without without making you uh you
know fully explain all of his policies
when he says simple things like you know
we've had bad trade deals and we're
going to have better trade deals and all
that I think a lot of people watch it
and me to to some degree I watch it and
I go well this is a guy who's a
businessman I get it he's used the
bankruptcy laws to his Advantage he
sells ties and other places also to his
Advantage no he might be a he might be a
great businessman being a good
businessman doesn't mean you know
anything about economics right and
doesn't so so but when he says that
stuff do you so you just think it's
complete nonsense that he can't NE
negotiate trade deals any better cuz
that's just simply not there is no such
thing as a negotiated better trade deal
the best trade policy and look Adam
Smith wrote about this in the wealth of
nation 200 in 1776 right um Ricardo
wrote about this in the 19th century
there's no Economist left or right
almost no Economist because there's
always some wacko somewhere but there's
no Economist left or right and this is
why Alan Blinder wrote about this right
he's a leftist economist he's a
Keynesian I disagree with him on so much
but there's almost no Economist who who
doesn't believe that the best trade
policy for the United States from a
wealth maximizing for Americans for
individual Americans is zero tariffs
just take tariffs in America and put
them at zero and let the rest of the
world do whatever the hell they want now
for those countries for China the best
trade policies is for them to lower it
to zero and if we lowered it to zero
they would they would have lots of
pressure internally to lower it I'm
against trade deals right because I
think we should just do it ourselves now
some people gonna suffer as a
consequence within the United States
sure some people lose their jobs and
they're going to have to figure out new
jobs but other jobs will be created and
the net effect clearly again shown by
economists for 200 plus years is that
the US economy and individuals within
the US become richer wealthier more
successful it's the same as if a plant
leaves California and goes to Nevada do
do we get all apoplectic about oh my God
how awful no I mean they made the
decision they made the decision it's
cheap over there uh the fact is that you
know in this case we can import the
stuff from Nevada import it right we
don't even think in those terms the the
the stuff is going to be cheaper produc
in Nevada so therefore we'll buy it for
cheaper we'll have more money to consume
and other things or to say God forbid
save in America we don't believe in that
anymore but save some money invest it
and create the kind of businesses where
we in America have a comparative
advantage look 100 years ago 80% of
American population worked in far in
today less than 1% does and we produce
much more food than ever before by by a
long shot in 1979 manufacturing jobs
peaked in the United States we have half
the number of manufacturing jobs today
we produce more stuff than we ever have
ever most of that has nothing to do with
China anybody else most of that's
automation so it's just science and
technology has changed the world and new
jobs and new jobs are going to be out
there and it's not not just Science and
Technology globalization has changed the
world but that's great a billion people
a billion people have come out of
poverty in Asia over the last 30 years
that's a billion people me we should be
celebrating dancing in the streets
nobody talks about it because they came
out of poverty not because of a foreign
aid they came out of poverty because
those countries adopted a little bit of
free markets and because there's a
perception that they did it and we lost
jobs to some extent that's true but we
gain more jobs than we lost the fact is
that that then when when trade is free
in America unemployment is very very low
so a lot of people are going to be
listening to this and say but there
you're not offering any net any social
safety net for the people that need it
the most and at the same time if you're
saying that the minimum wage doesn't
work even for all the philosophical
reasons that you laid out they're going
to say but no matter what there's a
certain amount of people that need help
I gener I basically believe that which
is why I haven't fully uh Gone
libertarian so what's the response so I
agree there's certain number of people I
think it's very small by the way who
need help because I think capitalism in
all of history anywhere it's tried
creates more jobs than there are people
so anybody who is able can work and work
at a decent living where they can live
their life without a lot of help but
look emergencies happen bad stuff
happens to people and some people truly
cannot survive right they they've got
they've got problems whether whether
their brain is not developed enough or
their body is not developed enough
something they need to be taken care of
right so I believe in a safety net I
just don't believe the government should
provide it I don't believe I should be
cursed to help them right you want to
help them I want to help them we can get
together start a foundation so charity
is the safety in charity was the safety
in in the 19th century but not only
charity you know that in the 19th
century they sold insurance against
poverty they they were mutual Aid
societies where we would all go together
and buy insurance in a sense insuring
all of us uh you know a mutual type of
insurance deal in order to preent for
poverty or for if your house burned down
or kind of just generally bad stuff
happening in life um you could in a in a
true free market on healthcare for
example you could buy an insurance
policy maybe even for life on a baby
that hasn't been born yet I mean the
possibilities once you free up the
economy from regulations and controls if
you actually let people make decisions
based on their own interests
unbelievable so it's I don't believe
anybody's going to be dying in the
streets I don't believe anybody I I
believe the opposite I think fewer
people will die from poverty fewer
people will be hurt from poverty I think
people would be much richer much better
off and that the safety net that exists
will be much more effective and driven
primarily towards those people who for
no fault of their owner in the situation
some people deserve the Fate that they
get if you're a wife beating drunk
capitalism is not good for you yeah but
I'm all for that I Believe In Justice I
Believe In fairness fairness is not
equality fairness means getting what you
deserve and white beating drunks deserve
bad stuff happening to them so it's so
interesting to me how it really really
sounds like a branding issue because
people think of capital there's this
idea now that and I think it has a lot
to do with crony capitalism and the way
our politicians have allowed you know
corporations to basically steal from
America and you know hide money
elsewhere and hide taxes but but we have
course object to cronyism and the only
solution to cronyism is to shrink
government power so that government
doesn't get involved in business or
business doesn't have any incentive to
Lobby it so so that's basically Atlas
Shrug right there that was the you you
just gave me the one sentence the
smaller the government the less cron ISM
there is I mean there the famous story
about Microsoft in 1994 they were
brought in front of Congress and Arin
hatch who was then a young senator from
Utah land blasted them for not lobbying
for not having a presence in Washington
DC for not doing all the things that
Corporate America was expected to do and
and and Microsoft walked away and said
look you leave us alone we'll leave you
alone we're not interested yeah right
and of course six months later the
Justice Bond comes knocking uh goes
after Microsoft for giving a product
away for free
Internet Explorer destroys the company
from my perspective right today
Microsoft spends tens of millions of
dollars a year they have a beautiful
building in Washington DC about equal
distance from the capital and the White
House this is how it happens the
politicians come and they say give us a
handout or when we write the regulations
we're going to screw you wow I really
want to get into that for a second
because I remember that happening 1994 I
was I think a senior in high school I
remember that so Internet Explorer was
just the it was the internet browser
that was built into windows and
basically the government said you have a
monopoly on this right so but of course
Netscape invented uh web browsing they
were charging I think it was 50 or 70
bucks a pop and here was being being
bundled with the operating system and
Netscape was saying wait a minute we
can't compete against a a free product
you're dumping in a sense and this is
antitrust laws and I you know just
quickly antitrust laws and this is
absurdity of antitrust laws if you sell
a product really really cheap then
you're violating antitrust laws because
you're dumping if you sell a product
much more expensive than your
competitors you must have a monopoly so
so you're in violation of antitrust laws
and if you sell your product at the same
price as your competitors you're
colluding it must be collusion because
how would you sell it all at the same
price so that's like the the cell phone
companies if because everybody's within
five bucks antitrust is a law that is
meaningless it is completely at the
discretion of the regulator when to
apply it and when lot and that's what
authoritarians always love they love
laws that are not clear that are not
objective so they can choose you didn't
pay me this month I'm going to go after
you right you're not lobbying so I'm
going to go after you Google has learned
this right Google and Netflix and these
guys they spent huge amounts of lobbying
Democrats Republicans they spread it all
around it's interesting that Google has
no antitrust problems Apple does because
Apple does has Lobby very little right
right Microsoft did because it Lobby
zero so this is the game that's being
played and it's a game that is
determined by the politicians they're
the ones with the guns they're the ones
forcing this upon businessmen right so
is there a risk there though that if you
remove all of that stuff that the
companies eventually will become more
powerful than the government now I
suppose you wouldn't view that as a risk
per se but that Apple at this point that
Apple has more money than the government
right Apple Apple's in the in the black
you know look this is the difference
yeah and and this is a fundamental
confusion this is what you said a lot of
this is about Woods it's about Woods yes
but the deeper philosophical meaning of
words there's such a thing as economic
power and there's such a thing as
political power political power is about
coion it's about guns it's about Force
economic power is about voluntary
transactions I have no problem companies
gaining more and more and more economic
power they can only have that power as
long as I voluntarily choose to trade
with them I can choose to buy a Samsung
tomorrow I can choose to boycott Apple
for a variety of reasons if I want to
tomorrow there are other choices there
always are choices but there is the risk
that they could just buy every other
company and eventually never happened
never happened so the the a better mouse
trap will always come along right better
mous trap the classical example of this
is is uh Rockefeller right had 90 plus
percent of all oil oil refining in the
in the 19 in the 1870s right so Monopoly
so what were we Tau econ 101 prices go
up quality goes down never happened
prices went down every single year I
challenge anybody to look at the data go
down every year quality goes down every
year because Rockefeller understood that
if he raised prices competition would
come about and competition will often
come about from products you would never
expect so for example in the 1870s
rockefeller's oil was being used for
kerosene to light us who competed him
out of that business I guess the
uh who what bureaucrat what central
Planet would have sat back in 187 say
yeah this guy in that lab he's going to
compete nobody would have imagine that
that's the beauty of of real freedom of
real capitalism today of course Edison
would have never been allowed to have
the lab uh because he violated every
code in the book I'm sure he didn't
weigh goggles when he did his experiment
there's no way the Regulators would
allow that absolutely so in 19th century
had we had relative freedom and and the
consequence was the greatest pace of
innovation in human history the biggest
Innovative leaps in human history I mean
really today we get another app and we
get all excited electricity was invented
right right lighting uh think of all the
stuff that comes from electricity and
then think of the trains automobiles
airplanes I mean the innovation in in
the 19th century early part of the 20th
century are massive today the little
incremental so is that possible that
just sort of the Arc of humanity has
changed where those those things no so
you think it's it's boundless it really
is I think it's boundless and I think
what's constraining today is our
educational system which is pathetic
particularly in science and math and and
the things way we teach kids to to to to
think and I think it's um it's polit
political I think when you regulate
people when everything you do is by
permission people don't take risks
people don't challenge themselves and
this is what I meant by the enemy of the
mind is the gun if I put a gun to your
back of your neck and say these things
you cannot do it shuts down whole parts
of the mind and this is exactly what the
enlightenment was fighting against this
is the whole idea of free speech and
free inquiry was the idea is you can't
shut down the human mind you can't shut
it down in science you can't shut it
down in philosophy or SL religion you
can't SL you can't shut it down when it
comes to business because what you do
when you do that is you destroy whole
areas of inquiry and some of those
inquiries will be wrong I mean some
experiments you know blow up in your
face right but you got to you got to
fail in order to be successful when we
bail people out when we don't allow
restructurings when we don't allow the
dynamism that exists we suffer the
reason we have so much innovation in
Silicon Valley is because that is the
least regulated industry in our economy
the reason Wall Street keeps collapsing
is because it is the most regulated
industry in now we can't so okay so Wall
Street is regulated and we bail them out
and when they're too big to fail we make
them bigger sure so I get all that so
what would the alternative been if we
had just actually let them all fail I
mean people basically say Obama sa
that's a false Al right the alternative
is 80% regulation or 90% regulation no
the alternative is zero right the
alternative is unwind the system the
alternativ US to get rid of the you know
pages and pages and book loads of
regulations over the financial industry
free them up completely that will
probably lead to a completely different
looking banking system than what we have
today but also make it clear we're not
going to bail you out when you deposit
money in the bank because there's no
deposit insurance right but we're also
not going to bail any banks out when
they get in trouble we just stepping
back and letting the market be free and
look before 1913 the United States had
no federal reserve it had no bank balot
and it had Bank regulations particularly
in state level which were disastrous but
and generally the economy grew the
fastest in human history from from the
Civil War until till World War I it was
an amazing period of of of economic
growth and economic success without a
Fed without central
planners that's what I'd like to see
what the the lesson of 2008 is get rid
of the Federal Reserve the lesson of
2008 is stop regulating the banks and
the Credit Agencies and the rating
agencies and all these things that
distort market so my Bernie people are
not going to be happy with you because
you're both address you're both saying
there's a problem here you're saying the
problem is the government is
artificially uh controlled what Wall
Street can do he would say uh we have to
we have to control them even more and
I'm saying we've tried Bernie's solution
since the Great Depression right during
the Great Depression the first thing FDL
did when he came into office in 33 34
it's passed massive bodies of financial
regulations since then we've had
inflation we've had the SNL crisis we've
had 2008 those regulations that were
passed in 33 and 34 don't work they
never worked they they they were they
were disastrous from the beginning it
just takes decades to see their for
manifestation the solution is not to
load up on them a whole new set of the
same bad thing you don't if if you run
an experiment and it doesn't work you
don't double up on the experiment right
what you do is you rethink your your
your fundamental ideas about it and we
need to rethink Finance from the
beginning yeah so I love that this
really all comes down to human nature
right because if you were let's say you
were of the Bernie mindset and you say
we have to regulate the more I guess
what he would say is or what you would
say is well someone even if with all the
regulations on Earth someone because of
human nature is going to come in and
figure out a way to still screw it up no
no it's the regulations that are
screwing the Sy system up right the
regulations cause crisis the regulations
provide the incentives for people to
behave in particular ways that are
screwy I'm saying is the reason we don't
TR We Trust regulation and we don't
trust markets and this is the key right
yeah because in every field this is true
a crisis happens we regulate it which
causes another crisis to happen we
regulate even more which causes a bigger
crisis and this was observed by irand in
the 50s and 40s this is a new phenomena
this is the way government functions
this is the way human beings function is
the fun Al we don't trust is
self-interest we think that
self-interest leads to lying stealing
cheating all this bad behavior so we
regulate it right so all that happens is
the regulations caused incentives to be
misaligned and bad things to happen so
we oh no it's greed it's self-interest
again so we regulate even more I'm
saying that if we trust that
self-interest if we got and why do we
trust The Regulators why why do we you
walk into an elevator anywhere in the
United States and there's a little
diploma on the elevator thing says a
government regulator inspector this
elevat won't kill you and why do we go
oh okay now it's safe because the the
elevator inspector we believe is for the
public interest he's on the common good
he's not self-interested God forbid be
self-interested he's just doing it for
all of us and I'm saying that's a bogus
imal standard I don't want people to be
in the public interest the public
interest means nothing so you think
these elevator guys are just walking in
there and signing that sheet I'm saying
that the guy who inspects the elevator
as a government employee is probably
much more open to bribes than if the
inspection of the elevators was done by
the insurance company that if the
something bad happened to the elevator
they would suffer Financial cost and
that guy would be fired the elevated
inspector hired by the government will
never be fired he's got 10 take food
inspectors in California California
farmers are much more worried about the
grocery store inspectors than they are
about the the the government inspectors
because the grocery store has something
to lose if they poison us right the the
inspector from the government has
nothing to lose this is why when when
Ben banki Ben banki in my view is one of
the most awful Federal Reserve chairman
ever he screwed up 08 he completely
messed up 07 he the he the recovery's
being the slowest in in history
everything that fed did everything he
said in 0708 turned out to be wrong he
was wrong about everything he said the
housing crisis wouldn't happen it
wouldn't cause a recession Freddy and
Fanny were fine Leeman Brothers wasn't
going to go backround I've got a list of
all his statements they're all wrong
what happened to him he got rehired and
today he gets a quarter of a million
dollars to give a speech right he he's
become a
hero what happened to the private
Bankers who actually drove their
businesses who did what the FED did to
their own businesses they're out of jobs
yeah they're not behind jails I know bun
would like them all in jail but they
they they've suffered the consequences
they've lost their jobs nobody wants to
talk to them nobody will hire them again
that's what happens in business in
business if you fail you're out
government when you fail you we reward
you particularly if you're in the
bureaucracy right so I'm saying let's
shift the model to where
we we trust individuals we trust their
self-interest We Trust we we leave
companies alone and if the companies do
bad things let them fail we can boycott
them if we don't like the way they
behave towards I don't know gays or
whatever if we don't like the their
behavior don't don't go to Chick-fil-A
just don't buy Chick-fil-A boycott them
that's right so this is where you would
say if the if the Christian pizza maker
doesn't want to make pizza for gays you
wouldn't say let the government stop
them from doing that you would say well
boycott them and don't give them
business and yes but I I want to be a
little bit more radical than that
because because this is the problem we
have Ted Cruz and people like that
talking about religious freedoms what
religious freedom I just believe in
Freedom and the fact is that people have
a right to discriminate so I would
expend it if the don't give them your
business yeah don't get so so my point
is this if the baker doesn't want to
give doesn't want to bake a cake for a
Jewish wedding he has just as much right
to do that as he has to discriminate but
I would never go near the plate I would
I would I would I would stand outside
with a placard I'd be on the barricades
to drive that immoral Bastard out of
business right but but he has a right to
be a bigot people have a right to be
racist they just don't have a right to
force it on you yeah I'm with you on
that I you know some of my friends on
the left will say well but they're using
you know the public street that they're
on so then they they we wouldn't want
them to discriminate against black
people and I get the idea behind that
but once they walk off the public Street
into your store it's yours I I am very
discriminating and who I invite to my
home it's not discrimination based on
race or any of these other factors but
people who I think are nice or invited
people who I don't like are not invited
we all discriminate discrimination is a
good thing what we need to teach people
is not to discriminate based on stupid
things or non-essential things you
discriminate based on a person's
character that's the appropriate
discrimination but are they always going
to be irrational people are they always
going to be stupid people they always
going to be bad people yes but we the
job job of the government is not to
legislate them out of their stupidity
the job of the government is to let them
suffer the consequences of their
stupidity which means back off yeah uh
we bar we barely got into this here so I
I I certainly hope you'll come back so
we can unpack more absolutely would be
happy to yeah this was a pleasure and I
think I'm looking forward to the uh to
the comment section because it's it's
going to be wild all right I want to
thank your own Brooke for joining me
today you guys can follow him on Twitter
it's at your own Brook and he does
respond and he'll fight with you and
send you links and maybe he'll send you
some of these pamphlets and you can
check out his book equal is unfair in
the description right down below
thanks